you
hello everybody this is Margaret Harris
welcoming new to our w-h-o press
briefing from Geneva thanks for your
patience not on this Friday July 10
today we want to tell you something
about something really exciting a new
and exciting initiative called the
Access Initiative for quitting tobacco
to help over 1 billion tobacco users
quit and reduce the risk of Kogi at 19
the lineup will be led by of course the
w-h-o director-general dr. Ted Rose dr.
Ted Rose adenoma per se us followed by
the her Royal Highness Princess Tina
myriad of Jordan the president for the
Union for international cancer control
and a global advocate for tobacco
control she will be followed by mr.
Tibor mungyeong executive vice president
worldwide chairman consumer health for
Johnson & Johnson and then after hearing
about this new initiative will move to
our regular kovat 19 press briefing so
without further ado I'll hand over the
doctor tell us to begin proceedings dr.
Ted Ross you have the floor Thank you
Thank You Margaret
good morning good afternoon and good
evening today the Bleacher is launching
the access initiative for quitting
tobacco which aims to help the world's
1.3 billion tobacco users quit during
the pandemic this initiative will help
people freely access the resources they
need to quit tobacco like nicotine
replacement therapy and access to a
digital health worker for advice
smoking kills 8 million people a year
but if users need more motivation to
kick the habit the pandemic provides the
right incentive evidence reveals that
smokers are more vulnerable than
non-smokers to developing a severe case
of copied 19 the project is led by WH er
together with the UN interagency task
force or non communicable disease
and brings together the tech industry
pharmaceutical and NGO partners like
path and the coalition for access to NCD
medicines and products we tank our first
manufacturing partners Johnson Johnson
consumer health who donated nearly 40
thousand nicotine pipes we're also
pleased to introduce Florence the world
and WHS first-ever digital health worker
based on artificial intelligence
Florence dispels myth around copied 19
and tobacco and helps people develop a
personalized plan to quit
Florence is available 24/7 via video
stream or text to help people access
reliable information Florence was
created with technology developed by San
Francisco and New Zealand based
companies all machines we support from
Amazon Web Services and Google Cloud W a
choice in the final stages of adding
more partners and encourages
pharmaceutical and tech companies to
join this initiative which will help
people reduce their risk of copied 19
and lead healthier lives
we will first launched the initiative in
Jordan and then roll it out globally
over the coming months to tell you more
about this initiative I would like to
introduce my sister Her Royal Highness
Princess Dena of Jordan princess Dena is
a longtime friend the President of the
Union for international cancer control
and a lifelong advocate for Global
tobacco control you have the floor
princess and you here thank you dr. Ted
Rose for this innovative and life-saving
initiative cupboard 19 has required us
all to Don masks and yet ironically at
the same time it has unmasked too many
uncomfortable truths one of those
glaring truth is that some smoking
tobacco in all of its forms new and old
electronic and non electronic has shown
us all that has no benefits whatsoever
to its users on the contrary it depletes
one's health once hard-earned money and
now also puts the user in the highest
risk pool for not only contracting of it
19 but also in spreading it as well as
not being able potentially to fight and
survive the virus due to higher
vulnerability to severe complications I
thank you dr. Tetris from the bottom of
my heart for your leadership for not
only facing off with the coronavirus
which is a hair coolly and tasked to say
the least but also in not neglecting the
so-called underlying conditions non
communicable diseases and CDs such as
heart disease cancer lung disease and
diabetes the epidemics that remain the
major causes of preventable deaths in
the world
totaling over 40 million in 2016 on the
contrary dr. cadra
you are maintaining and doubling down on
our work to prevent and control those
epidemics and the risk factors that
caused them starting with tobacco that
is said to kill a billion this century
if we do not do something about it
Jordan my beloved country has
unfortunately been one of the many
countries on the target list of the
global tobacco industry the latter which
lost its markets in developed countries
and now doubling their efforts in
ensnaring
and owning the lungs of our youth to
consume the dubbed deadly product
according to a national survey in 2019
tragically this has resulted in the
deadly statistic of eighty two and a
half percent of our men over 18 using
tobacco or a cigarettes one of the high
traits in the world and 60% of our youth
between the ages of 13 to 15 are
addicted to smoking not only does this
impact
cancer and other entities that is why I
am beyond pleased that Jordan will be
the first country to launch the access
initiative for quitting tobacco this
emphasizes the fact that smoking
addiction is a disease that needs to be
treated thus these stigmatizing smokers
who often feel blamed and shunned or
their own addiction despite the fact
that we all know that most users are
victims of the tobacco industry's well
known tactics to trap the youth before
they reach maturity and adulthood this
initiative will also have Jordanian
access the information and tools they
need to quit
I hope Florence speaks Arabic by the way
but also offers them the nicotine
replacement therapies and medications
necessary to aid them in their journey
of quitting and starting to lead
healthier lives Jordan is a proud party
of the Framework Convention on tobacco
control and has a strong group of
grassroots NGOs fighting for tobacco
control I might say most of them are
women just an FYI that is shaking the
status quo and improving step by step
the enforcement of the law in Jordan
just last week the government of Jordan
adopted the ban on smoking indoors in
public places the link between smoking
and covered 19 make it essential for
governments to pass comprehensive
tobacco control laws that will protect
the health of their people during this
pandemic and beyond we must do better
with this new initiative the government
can show that Jordan is invested in
strengthening tobacco control measures
and saving lives by implementing proven
measures based on FCTC
and WH OHS empowered like banning
tobacco use in public spaces
I would like to sign w-h-o again and for
you dr. Tetris personally for leading
this innovative initiative and all of
our partners for their support including
Johnson & Johnson for the significant
donation of nicotine patches this will
help thousands of people overcome the
to nicotine and support them in their
journey to healthy life and free of
addiction
thank you dr. Ted rose again for your
leadership we are so proud of you and we
are thinking of your day and they are
for all your efforts on fighting the
covered 19 and on making sure that we
don't lose ground on all the games with
it in public health thank you for
everything and yes I feel so honored
that you also called me call me your
sister and a friend and I feel the same
way and thank you for Johnson and
Johnson thank you
thank you so much princess Dina for
those really powerful words and the
great news about the actions being taken
in in Jordan on tobacco control and also
for your support for the work against
kovat 19 I'd now like to introduce mr.
Chiba Mong gong the chairman and the
executive vice president my apologies
worldwide chairman consumer health for
Johnson & Johnson mr. Monken you have
the floor yes hi everyone and we are
very very pleased to be joining you
today we are we are committed to change
the trajectory of health or humanity as
we all have today and in this initiative
will really help people quit smoking
this is a very important public health
milestone it was made possible through
the close collaboration between public
and private partners and this is I
believe what makes its potentials to
succeed even greater and when we hear
Princess Di when we hear commitment I
have no doubt that this program is going
to be very very successful starting with
Jordan but expanding well beyond Jordan
in the in the future months as we all
know good health is impossible without
access to the right tools we just heard
about AI and the right products and in
terms of smoking cessation we know that
one simple patch of nicotine replacement
therapy can change the trajectory of the
health of a smoker and this is what we
are talking about here one smoke at a
time but with a commitment to a
large-scale impact allowing smoker to
change the trajectory of their own
health and this is what gets all of us
Johnson Johnson & Johnson very excited
about this program our ability to make a
difference it will require as always the
commitment from all of us many different
players the continued leadership from
the WHL government NGOs industry but no
now we covered more than ever we really
need to rally the world behind this this
opportunity to change the trajectory of
the health of so many people around the
world so with this objective in mind
Johnson Johnson consumer health is is
proud to build upon changes
long-standing collaboration with the WH
CEO and participate to the program with
the nation of free products for smokers
in need and we are really committed to
continuing to provide access to
Nicorette nicotine replacement therapy
around the world because we know that so
many people around the world need our
help to quit smoking and get access to a
better health the better life and a
better future so thank you to all
participants and thank you for you
unwavering commitment to this very very
important issue t we are counting on all
of you to make it very successful thank
you so much mr. mungol for all that
you're doing to help smokers beat this
terrible addiction now I don't know if
you're as curious as me but I'd like to
know who this Florence is and we now
have a video which I'd like to entitle
the unmasking of Florence there's
nicotine help protect you from carbon 19
there is currently insufficient
information to any link between tobacco
or nicotine in the prevention or
treatment of kovin 19:18 replacement
therapies such as nicotine gum and
patches are designed to help smokers
quit tobacco would you like to hear
another kovat nineteen mythbuster sure
yeah thank you thank you Margaret that's
our first-ever digital health worker and
I hope she will give all the support
people need and she is available 24/7 as
I said earlier again thank you so much
my sister princess Dina and also thank
you to dr. Monken we really appreciate
thank you for joining us and now back to
copied 19 today the world recorded 12
million cases in the last six weeks
cases have more than doubled across all
walks of life where we're all being
tested to the limit for those in poverty
with little or no access to quality
health services it's not only copied 19
that threatens lives and livelihoods
other diseases like measles polio and
malaria all thrive when immunization is
posed and supply chains for medical
supplies are interrupted WH er continues
to work with partners to ensure that the
poorest and most marginalised are
prioritized that means we starting
routine immunization and ensuring that
medical supplies reach health workers
across the world there is a lot of work
still to be done from countries where
there is exponential growth to places
that are loosening restrictions and now
starting to see cases rise we need
leadership community participation and
collective solidarity only aggressive
action combined with national unity and
global solidarity can turn this pandemic
around there are many examples from
around the world that have shown that
even if the outbreak is very intense it
can still be
wrote back under control and some of
these examples are Italy Spain South
Korea and even in the Harvey a densely
packed area in the mega mega city of
Mumbai a strong focus on community
engagement and the basics of testing
tracing isolating and treating all those
that are sick is key to breaking the
chains of transmission and suppressing
the virus as we continue to tackle the
pandemic we are also looking into the
origins of the virus to WH er experts
are currently and route to China to meet
to meet with fellow scientists and learn
about the progress made in understanding
the animal reserve r4 copied 19 and how
the disease jumped between animals and
humans
this will help lay the groundwork for
the WHI led international mission into
the origins for all the challenges that
covet 19 has caused it has also shown
the way forward for other challenges
that threaten humanity the crisis of
growing and microbial resistance is a
slow-motion tsunami were despite the
rise in resistant infections the
research and development of new
antibiotics has not caught up unless we
take quick and sustained action we risk
a drumstick global scenario where common
injuries and illnesses return to become
major killers the AMR Action Fund aims
to tackle this by strengthening and
accelerating the research and
development of antibiotics through
game-changing investments into
biotechnology companies around the world
whether it's kovat 19 or AMR the best
shot we have is to work together
in national unity and global solidarity
I thank you thank you so much dr. Ted
Roz Arno often the flood questions do
remember we will be as usual we'll be
providing simultaneous translation in
all six UN languages and also Portuguese
so if you prefer to ask your questions
in any of those languages please do you
may all also listen in Hindi but you
cannot ask you ask your questions and no
too
owing to the way zoom is set up you will
need to go to the button marked Korean
to access Arabic with dr. tariffs we
have our usual experts dr. Maria van
care cough technical lead for coded
doctor Michael Ryan executive director
emergencies and joining them is also dr.
rüdiger Krish director of health
promotion who can answer your questions
about the Access Initiative for quitting
tobacco so without further ado I will go
to the first question and that is for
Sarah Wheaton from Politico so Sarah
please unmute yourself and go ahead yes
thank you very much for taking my
question it's about the timing of the
independent review panel that you
announced yesterday and when we've asked
about this in the past after the World
Health Assembly dr. Ted Drewes you said
that you would start you would initiate
the review and all the conditions we
need we need are actually met and dr.
Ryan you noted that these are typically
launched after the crisis is over
furthermore the independent oversight
and by3 committee for the W Cho
emergencies program said in their
interim report that while they
recommended a review they said and I'm
quoting conducting such a review during
the heat of the response even in a
limited manner could disrupts wh o--'s
ability to respond effectively so dr.
Ted Rose what conditions that used that
needed to be met have have now been met
and dr. Ryan and dr. Ted Rose are you
concerned about the effect on the
response of the review happening thank
you
yes I can I can begin well first of all
we're very used in certain emergencies
program and whu-oh of constant process
of of operational review both during and
after events and that's reviewing how
our operations are running so we can
improve those operations so that that's
a very important part of our DNA in
terms of optimizing the impact that we
have a country level the the independent
oversight and Advisory Committee also
reports to our governing bodies as you
know to the Executive Board and the
World Health Assembly a six monthly
basis and again reviews all of our
operations on the ground this evaluation
that has been mandated by the World
Health Assembly asking the
director-general
to carry out an independent evaluation
that is the will of the member states of
whu-oh we believe that is has been
constructed in good faith to learn the
lessons that we're learning so far it is
presented as both a process of gaining
interim learning from the response so
far and therefore the first part of the
review is to gain and learn and about
the response how we have all performed
in this at global and national level and
how we can learn to optimise the
response going forward however they
obviously a review of this nature and
with with the seniority of the panel
members or the panel chairs will work
with the member states now to identify
further panel members to join that panel
and it will be they that will set the
pace for that review and they will
consult with the member states again
they will consult and work with the
Director General to ensure that the the
pace nature of the evaluation does not
interfere with the day-to-day responsive
and and I trust given the seniority of
the of the two wonderful leaders that
have been chosen
I believe they and the panel members the
member states and the director general
of whu-oh will find the appropriate pace
and the appropriate approach that will
allow us both
the lessons of this response at all
levels but at the same time not to
interrupt or disrupt but is a very
important endemic response right now
thank you thank you I think my god
already said it all the decision in the
resolution by the assembly was at the
earliest appropriate time and it gives
the responsibility actually to to me
which is very important so that you know
we can have a balancing act so that the
evaluation doesn't affect the response
and that's why the member states didn't
make it very specific they said at the
appropriate earliest appropriate time
and we felt that starting it now
can really help us to understand as we
respond how the whole response is is
happening and as Mike said we will
continue to make sure that the
evaluation actually doesn't affect the
response and we will do we will balance
as much as possible so it's a matter of
balancing act and we have variable two
co-chairs now and the panel members also
we expect them to be the best people we
can really have and all member states
will be involved in contributing to the
panel members some candidates of course
it will be up to the co-chairs in
consultation with me to select the
members and I think that will also
hopefully help us in in balancing the
capacity of the panel itself and there
will be an independent Secretariat it's
no we're not going to use WH a
Secretariat for for the for the panel
meaning we will have additional manpower
that will work on this not only the
panel but the independent Secretariat
too
so we will do everything to to balance
it but as the independent oversight
advisory committee said it's also our
concern that you know the mid you know
evaluatee evaluation in the middle of
everything - in order to as we go thank
you question comes from Antonio Antonio
you're welcome to go ahead still
constant America and convenience must I
think that's fundamentally important
observation actually and I think that it
was to be expected I think we and many
other scientists around the world have
said that once
lockdowns were were ended that there was
always the risk that the disease could
bounce back because if the virus is
present it will potentially take all
opportunities to transmit our advice has
been I think quite consistent in
advising countries number one to open up
slowly in a stepwise fashion to wait
between
different phases of reopening to ensure
that the data and the virus is clean and
clear and tells you where your problems
are to be ready to move backwards or
forwards depending on what that data is
telling you and to accept the fact that
in our current situation it is very
unlikely that we can eradicate or
eliminate this virus there are very
particular environments in which that
can occur Island States and other places
but even there risk
reincarnation and we've seen countries
who've managed to get to zero or almost
zero re-import virus from websites so
there's always a risk either from within
or from bringing disease back in and
therefore it is a given that there is
always a risk of further cases the
transmission that occurs in that
situation can be single sporadic cases
which can be relatively easily isolated
and quarantined and we're worrying
pattern is large clusters of cases that
could occur in association with super
spreading events events in which there
are large crowds gather the virus is
present and you get a small explosion of
cases which can very quickly mushroom
into a much larger case it's very
analogous to a forest fire a small fire
it's hard to see but it's easy to put
out a large fire is hard to see or easy
to see but very difficult to put out so
you really need a system where you can
detect the small flames the small embers
that may be there you can detect a small
fire and put that out by good
surveillance by good detection by
aggressive testing and then by isolating
cases quarantine in cases throughout all
of this and I think this is probably
very central message that when the virus
is present there is a risk of spread the
authorities can have surveillance in
place the authorities need to have that
in place isolation quarantine all of
those are those measures and testing but
ultimately it comes down to communities
and individuals and how we protect
ourselves and how we protect others when
the virus is in your community the guy
it is quite clear that there are things
you and your community can do to reduce
the risk of those infections and it's
very important that people feel
empowered that they have the knowledge
to be
able to do that so it requires a very
strong partnership a trusting
partnership between communities and the
Terra sees a trusting partnership based
on honesty based on transparency based
on regular information that everybody
can trust and based on a sustained
effort by everybody it is very tough
right there it is very tough for
everyone to maintain the kind of
vigilance that people are being asked to
maintain it is tough it's not easy but
we have to be able to sustain that so if
we want to avoid after a lockdown
having major epidemics we need to watch
out for the small clusters and we need
to extinguish those clusters quickly we
all need to remain vigilant
we need to marry in vigilant with our
physical distancing with our hygiene but
mask wearing in the appropriate settings
in that situation we can potentially
avoid the worst of having second Peaks
and having to have to move backwards in
terms of locked up it is also and you've
seen this in a number of countries are
managing to deal with clusters and and
with flare-ups by having limited
geographic lactose locking down small
areas in order to contain the disease
and I think it is a matter of scale
countries can and should be able to
contain the disease through those
measures we all want to avoid whole
countries going back into total lockdown
that is not a desire that anybody has
but there may be situations in which
that is the only option but they this is
a fundamental question right now for
everyone for every community for every
society it is going to require sustained
effort it's going to require a lot of
trust it's going to require clear
messaging it's going to enquire a huge
investment of sustained public health
effort and a massive investment in
community empowerment and the capacity
of us as individuals and our communities
to act and to stay safe
thank you Mike yes so I mean as Mike has
said I think this is something we all
need to anticipate that there's the
possibility that there could be a
resurgence there could be these small
outbreaks but I think what we had been
and have been advising is in these
situations is to act faster to act
comprehensively you know use the public
health infrastructure that you have in
place many countries have worked
incredibly hard to improve the
infrastructure that's in place to be
able to find cases test cases isolate
cases very quickly in if they have
symptoms if they develop disease to
ensure that they are cared for
appropriately in the appropriate
facilities to put contact tracing to the
test carry out contact tracing as as
comprehensively as possible quarantine
the contacts so that you break those
chains of transmission and inform inform
the communities often regularly honestly
thoroughly because the situation is
evolving and we know how quickly these
embers can really turn into these forest
fires and with that hope that if
restrictions need to be put in place
they're put in place temporarily they're
put in place in a limited geographic
region only to help and that they're not
put in place for long periods of time
but it is possible that these small
outbreaks that these small clusters can
be prevented into being turned into
large outbreaks we've seen this time and
time again so it is possible and and as
Mike has said and as we have said be
part of the response everyone has a role
to play if you're asked to stay home and
you can stay home please do if you're
feeling unwell stay home call your
health care provider to find out call
the hotline find out the next steps that
you need you need to take because
everybody needs to play a part in this
and it will take some times while we
take some time when we figure out how to
get through this together but it is to
be expected but we have tools in place
and governments have worked incredibly
hard communities have worked very hard
individuals have worked very hard we
just need to put those tools in use
again
Thank You dr. Rehn and dr. Van Kirk off
as the next question comes from Ben Chen
from Shanghai Media Group in if you wish
to speak ask your question in Chinese
we've got the translation service so
please do I thank you I think I will
continue to ask my question in English
thank you for taking my question so my
question is a follow-up regarding the
independent panel we currently know that
the panel's teachers are selected and
they could shoot other panel members so
I would like to ask how many more panel
members will be selected and experts in
which areas are the panel and the WHI
exactly looking for for example
policymakers medical professionals or
specialists in public health thank you
yeah thank you so the number of the size
of the panel there was some discussion
of course but not yet decided and the
co-chairs will decide finally as they
see fit and then the panel members of
course will be a mix of professionals
and again this will be up to the
co-chairs after developing the terms of
reference based on the terms of
reference to select people who would
really fit into the terms of reference
so these are things that are going to be
done once the co-chair start actually
working on this assignment thank you
thank you dr. Ted
the next question comes from jacqueline
Howard from CNN Jacqueline please unmute
yourself and go ahead yes thank you for
taking my question I wanted to ask we've
noticed reports circulating about an
ammonia in Kazakhstan that may be quote
deadlier than coal bed that's what some
of these reports are saying so I wanted
to ask if this is something that w-h-o
is investigating or can there be any
more information shared about whether
these reports are accurate or whether
this is something on your thank you yeah
yes this is certainly a narrator and
we've been tracking Accord 19 across all
of Europe and particularly in the
Central Asian Republics including
Kazakhstan the July the 5th as X then
went back into a lockdown as Co would 19
cases have actually spiked to the first
you
ported from sex time with 264 deaths the
there are a number of explanations that
can explain the reported rise in the
number of pneumonias in in Kazakhstan
and we're working with the authorities
there too to investigate more than ten
thousands laboratory confirmed cases of
cope with 19 have been reported by
national authorities over the last seven
days so there's been a big surge in
actual covert cases itself we're looking
at the at the actual testing and the
quality of the testing to make sure that
there haven't been false negative tests
for some of those other pneumonias that
have provisionally tested negative and
that is likely to be a major cause of
this that in that in many ways there
many of these pneumonia cases may also
will also be covert 19 they just have
not been diagnosed correctly but again
that remains to be seen and we're also
working with the authorities there to
look at x-rays and review x-rays and
look at the patterns of the new-moniest
to make sure that they're consistent
with covert 19 so while we believe that
many of these cases will be diagnosed as
covert 19 we keep an open mind we're
working very closely with authorities
our team on the ground is working very
closely with the authorities there to
track this and ensure that that that is
the case there are clusters of atypical
pneumonia can occur anywhere in the
world at any time can be caused by
diseases as wide-ranging as Legionella
chlamydia influenza and other things so
there are always other potential causes
for for clusters of atypical pneumonia
and we always keep an open mind until we
have definitive diagnosis but they
upward trajectory of covert 19 cases in
the country would suggest that many of
these cases are in fact undiagnosed
cases of Corbett 19 but as I said we
keep an open mind until we have an
absolute confirmation of the diagnosis
of these clusters
thank you doctor
and now we have a question from Helen
brands well from stat news Helen could
you unmute yourself and please go ahead
hi thanks very much for taking my
question I think it's from Mike Mike
give us an update on the Ebola outbreak
in Ecuador province in DRC thank you yes
Helen I will what we'll do is maybe pass
to another question and I'll come I'll
come back on that because I want to give
you some numbers you're a numbers person
so I can give you the general answer but
I can give you maybe more specific
numbers driven answer in a few minutes
so if you could take the next question
I'll just pull out the numbers for for
Helen thanks Helen so I put you at the
end of the queue but you will definitely
come back to you okay so now we have a
question for from Jacques Okayama from
NHK Japan so Shoku could you unmute
yourself and go ahead can you hear me
very well please go ahead thank you for
taking my question so my question is
regarding the airborne transmission
according to the science scientifically
released yesterday airborne transmission
of the virus can occur in health care
settings and somehow to make reports
related to indoor crowded spaces have
suggested the possibility of Aaron's own
transmission based on the evidence you
have so far do you recognize the
airborne transmission as a realistic
danger in our daily lives and what's
your recommendation to the general
public
thank you so thanks for the question
and yes so you've highlighted a
scientific brief that we published
yesterday on transmission of the cove
Cove in 19 of the SARS Kobe - virus that
causes cope in 19 and in this scientific
brief it's not a guidance document it's
a brief which summarizes all available
literature and evidence that we have
about how the virus is transmitted when
the buyers transmit speech
people as it relates to their infection
and what this means in terms of breaking
chains of transmission we look at
droplet we look at aerosol we look at
fall might we look at fecal-oral we look
at lots of different modes and our
attempt to do this is to consolidate
everything that we know about this virus
it's not a systematic review and there's
new literature being published and being
released every single day so this is a
living review we call this a living
review which means it will be updated
regularly within the brief we talked
about droplet and we talked about
aerosol your specific questions about
aerosol transmission an aerosol
transmission is one of the modes of
transmission that we have been concerned
about since the beginning particularly
in health care settings where there are
known to be these medical procedures
called airborne generating aerosol
generating procedures where we know that
these droplets can be aerosolized which
means that the particles could stay
suspended in the air for longer periods
of time in those situations where the
the health worker is actually carrying
out those procedures and for people
working in those areas we recommend
airborne precautions which is a certain
type of personal protective equipment
for health workers outside of healthcare
settings there is the possibility that
there could be aerosol aerosolized
particles in specific settings like
indoor settings where there are crowded
conditions where there's poor
ventilation and where people are
spending prolonged periods of time and
so what we've seen is that there are
some outbreaks that have been reported
in these closed indoor settings with
poor ventilation which include what you
had mentioned the nightclubs which have
included choirs fitness centers where
airborne transmission could cannot be
ruled out in those outbreaks there could
also be the droplet transmission and
full might the contaminated surface
transmissions what we are calling for is
more systematic research to be done in
these types of settings so it's not just
how and when transmission happens it's
the settings in which they happen so we
need a much better understanding of
these particular settings in these
outbreaks that are happening so that we
could better understand how transmission
is happening in terms of everyday life
every everyday life we recommend a
comprehensive set of package
which include physical distancing which
does include hand hygiene and
respiratory etiquette which includes the
use of fabric masks when you cannot do
physical distancing and to ensure that
when you have these close settings that
you have good ventilation so it's a
combination of packages but the dominant
routes of transmission from all of the
available evidence and our understanding
and working with large groups of
different disciplines collectively is
droplet in contact although there may be
other modes of transmission which we
don't rule out so we have requested and
we will be through our rnd blueprints
which we began working on since February
is to accelerate research in this area
to make sure that we have
well conducted studies so that we could
better determine the different roles of
transmission different modes of
transmission and so that all of the
advice that we give is as up-to-date as
possible thank you very much dr. Van
Kirk oh now I have a question from Simon
atiba from today News Africa who I
understand has a burning question about
smoking and kovat Simon please go ahead
thank you for taking my question this is
Simon atiba from today news African
Washington DC my first question was on
pregnant women he goes to dr. Mallya I
was wondering if WH one knows how this
virus affect pregnant women and if and
how it affect their babies then if you
may allow me I also would like to know
how if there is a correlation between Co
V 19 and smoking and if smoking makes
things worse at least better thank you
yes perhaps I can start with smoking
good afternoon we know that if you're a
smoker the likelihood of developing more
severe symptoms for kovetz a higher we
know that the the the way you
can attract kovetz is not yet
established whether there's a
combination with smoking at all so what
you can say is if your smoker you should
stop smoking straight away because of
the likelihood of having more severe
symptoms okay good question there so yes
so thank you for your question about
Coppa 19 and pregnant women
of course we are we are always concerned
about covin 19 in any and any population
and of course in particular pregnant
women what we understand from the
studies this is something our clinical
management team looks very closely at
and within our clinical guidance we have
specific recommendations for pregnant
women
we understand that among women who are
pregnant they don't seem to develop a
different type of disease than women of
the same age who are not pregnant
however there are some studies that have
come out recently that have looked at
pregnant women with underlying
conditions and if there are women with
underlying conditions they are at a
higher risk of developing more severe
disease and so that this is something we
need to ensure that we keep a close eye
on and ensure that that pregnant women
have the right care throughout their
pregnancies thank you very much dr. van
Kyoko so now we have a question from
Tamiya tape
Jameel please go ahead with your
question yes can you hear me Margaret
very well please go ahead very good
thank you very much for for taking my
question
we have seen in the last couple of days
President Bulls from out of taking
proudly his Clerke my question to you
did anything change in terms of studies
or are you still sticking to the point
that actually this drug at least so far
has not shown any kind of evidence in
terms of science what is your position
in terms of taking chlorine not to
reduce medical
specialized days but as for example
President Bush who not is taking at the
moment thank you very much
it's difficult to comment on any
specific individual use of
hydroxychloroquine and we have said many
times previously that I Roxy chloroquine
should be used in the context of Corbett
under only under strict medical
supervision we would assume that that is
the case in this case the the findings
regarding hydroxychloroquine for
hospitalized patients and do not
demonstrate differences in mortality
although there are lots of different
studies out there and at present to
reach out another price it's used in in
hospitalized patients on the basis that
the drug has now clearly demonstrated
the benefits to true those who take it
the but that is then for individual
clinicians to make determinations
regarding the use of the drug an
off-label basis we can only report what
we see from randomized control trials
and other observational studies and in
the end it is for national authorities
to determine what the use of the drug is
in their context and it is then
obviously for the use of for they for
individual clinicians to decide on how
to use that knowledge in the treatment
of their patients thank you very much
dr. Ryan and I have now have a question
from Gabriella
so to Maya Gabriella please unmute
yourself and go ahead in forth cast
knows para mexico en estos momentos de
la pan de Mia Jana meant ando los casos
esta semana SMSs milk associ re owes a
un solo dia y preocupa que un gran por
ciento de las nuevas no cure a los
pequeños entonces koalas
in prenta gracias
difficult to predict the trajectory of
any epidemic in in countries at the
moment but certainly at Mexico now has I
think the fifth highest call with 19
death toll and has had record-breaking
days in the last week recording nearly
7,000 cases on a single day with its
total cases now surpassing a quarter of
a million Mexico at the same time is is
in the process of reopening and in that
period the the number of cases has has
increased significantly and again this
is a pattern we've seen in many other
countries opening economies in the midst
of intense community transmission can
lead to an acceleration of cases that is
not unique at all to the Mexican
situation and Mexico like other
countries is balancing the demands of
communities to get back to work and and
to be able to earn livings with the
significant risk of increased and
intensified an accelerated corporate
trans transmission the so I think from
the perspective of Mexico Mexico and
other countries in this situation may
face increase and the continued increase
in cases over time because as I said in
previous intervention today if the virus
is present if the virus is transmitting
efficiently at community level and
communities continue to mix and engage
in normal activity and Public Health
surveillance is weak in that situation
and there's not the ability to identify
case as quickly as Maria has said
investigate quickly if these two things
don't work together in concert and if
you reach a point where the number of
cases exceeds the capacity of the public
health system to chase down the contacts
in cases exceeds the capacity of the
health system to cope with the number of
severe cases then we're right back where
we started
in in in in February and March work
systems effectively failing in the face
of the pressure
of the number of infected we need to try
and avoid that and again the question in
a country the size that is Mexico and
many other countries like it is to
really look at the sub-national level
see where the virus is under control of
where continued reopening continue to
understand where your hotspots are and
where you may have to slow down or
reverse parts of that reopening
intensify Public Health surveillance
intensify communications with with
communities and again it comes down to a
certain extent to trust there must be
consistent clear messaging on risk from
authorities from leaders and others we
must be honest with our communities
about the spread of the disease in our
communities we must communicate that
risk appropriately and we must give
people the information they need to
maintain proper social distance to
engage in proper personal hygiene to
wear masks were appropriate and we must
support our communities in doing that
and consistently message that's
inappropriate in an appropriate way
again it is difficult for countries
especially when the individual economic
consequences to individual families are
negative if you cannot go to work and
you cannot earn money and you cannot
feed your family
there is a huge consequence from that
when we fully understand the pressures
that people themselves are under and we
fully understand from that the pressures
that governments are under but we have
to find a way to balance these two
important issues we have to find a way
to balance the Co with 19 acceleration
against the economic reopening because
it's very very clear from a look from a
number of countries that opening in a
situation where you have intense
community transmission and weak public
health response leads to a difficult
situation that may push a whole country
back in terms of the progress that it
makes and that is that is not
inconsequential and blinds reopening not
associated with the careful stepwise
process based on data based on an open
communication may not lead to where
anybody wishes to go in any country
Mexico include
Thank You dr. Ryan
the next question is on kovaydin smoking
this one comes from Jim Roop Jim from
Westwood one radio news Jim please go
ahead
oh hi thank you very much as I look at
this question though that I typed to you
and I was happy if you would just pass
it along yourself that would have been
fine I appreciate this I realized this
is one of those stupid questions because
I think the answer is obvious but I'll
ask it anyway
the question was with koban 19 and
smoking her her Royal Highness said that
people who smoke are more likely to
contract the virus and also more likely
to spread it so my question was what's
the spreading aspect of it is it because
the virus can linger in smoke is it
because of the exhale factor is it
because when you smoke you don't wear a
mask and then I realized it's probably
all of the above but if I'm wrong you
can answer it if not then I guess dr.
Mikey can answer they Ebola in the drg
question thank you I can I can take you
that yeah as I said it leads to more
severe disease and that is the main
cause and that's why at the moment we
know that six hundred eighty million
people want to quit smoking and we know
that 400 million that's our latest
estimate we'll try to smoke we'll try to
stop smoking and that's the good news
and with today's initiative we hope that
we will be successful in really helping
20,000,000 to succeed in this so that's
actually the final estimates that we
have thank you very much dr. Chris I now
have a question from CAI Kufa Schmidt
and then we'll hear answer Hilliard's
question hi please go ahead Thanks
actually my question has already been
asked so let me use the chance to just
ask about how the way forward is looking
terms of and treatments I mean we
obviously you know have some negative
results on some some experimental
treatments is it becoming clearer what
the next ones are that need to be tested
because I think we're kind of getting to
that second phase I can I can start and
perhaps Michael would like to supplement
on this one because that's a big
question that you asked and it's a good
one what I can say is within our within
our clinical management Network and also
within the R&D blueprints you know that
there's a number of therapeutics and
drugs that are currently under
evaluation and those clinical trials are
underway there's a lot of small trials
and of course we have the Solidarity
trial that is underway what I what we
what the clinical Network is doing and
with with our D partners is working with
those that are carrying out those
clinical trials to follow them in real
time because many of them are small
there are possibilities that we could
try to combine the data coming in from
some of those studies so that we can get
a quicker answer to these questions I
don't have any specifics on which one is
the next one because I think that's the
the trillion dollar question here but I
think that there are a number of
therapeutics that are in development
that will will cover different aspects
of the disease whether they are you know
the prevention of developing more severe
disease or preventing people from dying
but there are a lot that are that are
currently underway and there's a huge
number of clinical trials Mike do you
want to add anything to that yeah no I
think I think you've said though I think
the the clinicians who came together
last week at the research firm
essentially that same view there are
lots of existing therapies we've seen
even today more day for suggesting that
some existing therapies for other
diseases may have some impact I think
this is important we continue to find
potential treatments in the drugs we
already have and being able to pick the
best of those candidates and bring them
into the Solidarity and other trials is
very important and that's why the
Solidarity recovery
and discovery trials were designed as
multi arms they allow us and other
partners in the UK France and other
places across many many countries to
bring in new drugs into that armory of
potential drugs they the bigger question
is new molecules and new drugs that are
being discovered because they obviously
have a much longer pathway to be used in
humans the advantage we have with
existing drugs is that many of them have
strong safety profiles and already
approved for use in other diseases and
they can be relatively easily introduced
into randomized control trials against
covert because we already have a strong
clinical the safety profile for those
drugs other drugs new molecules that are
developed have to go through the whole
rigor of the scientific the safety
discovery process and it takes much
longer to bring those drugs into
randomized control trials because they
have to go through primary safety
studies first and that does slow down
the process by which those molecules
become available but as Maria said there
are many many many of those molecules
currently in development and there are
other treatments like hyper immune
globulin which are clearly already being
used in trials and we also have
monoclonal antibodies which I think show
some great hope we've certainly used
monoclonal antibodies to very very good
effect
in Ebola income in Congo and I think
they've been groundbreaking in in in
reducing mortality both to maternal
antibodies have been highly successful
in reducing fatality and have
transformed the way we manage Ebola as a
disease in the field so I do think there
are some potential platforms types of
drugs out there that may result in in in
a much faster cycle to get those
diseases to all people who need them but
again it's a complex area and what we're
really really pleased for is the level
of collaboration between institutes
between clinicians between hospitals
between every different kind of
physician doctor nursing organization
out there i mean we've seen today
fantastic information summarized on the
neurologic impacts of
these disease we seen other fantastic
summaries of the cardiovascular impacts
and what we're seeing I think is one of
the fastest accelerations of knowledge
of the pathophysiology and the impact of
this disease and that in itself is
providing very interesting insights for
what we're treating so when we look at a
drug like dexamethasone currently in
trials we can attack this virus in two
ways we can attack the virus by treating
the virus in that sense trying to use
drugs that will impede the virus's
capacity to hurt us but we also have
countries the impact of the virus by
modern modulating the immune response to
the virus at certain stages which
prevents our systems overreacting and
dampening down inflammation we can we
also need to look under various other
interventions underway using statins and
other drugs that may prevent some of the
blood clotting impacts so we either have
to manage the virus itself or treat the
virus itself or the consequences of
having the virus and there's a
tremendous amount of good work underway
in that and the more we understand the
disease and its impact the more we can
design treatment pathways and options to
be used in future so I'm very hopeful in
terms of the levels of collaboration and
the levels of innovation the rendre way
and I'm very confident that we will find
therapies over time and I think it bodes
well for the future of emerging diseases
in general in general for our ability to
collectively deal with pandemics one of
the most important things in dealing
with a new disease is to gain an
understanding of how that virus or how
that disease operates in the human body
and understand how it impacts human
organs how it spreads and how it affects
the immune system the more we understand
that and the more rapidly we understand
that the more we create the space for
the innovators in the pharmaceutical and
the pharmacology side of things to
develop the countermeasures that we need
so I'm actually well we're desperately
needing more therapies I believe the
world probably at this point could not
be doing more collectively in order to
develop those countermeasures that we
need sorry to give it a specific example
of this science solutions in solidarity
one of the things that we're looking
into and dr. Janet Diez mentioned
the other day is actually trying to
operate a new model of working together
and we reached out to a number of pies
that are working on a specific
therapeutic for example so that they can
work with us on a prospective
meta-analysis where they agree to share
data on their individual trials and we
can actually pull this and we do these
analyses as the trials are still going
so that we are learning and that we are
able to understand how these
therapeutics work so that when we need
to adapt our guidance if we need to
adapt our guidance that could be done in
real time and that's a new model of
working and I and again as Mike has said
this is this is incredible
solidarity and collaboration to be able
to agree to share this as these trials
are ongoing so it's something that we
are trying it's something that we're
working very hard to do and we're very
grateful for the pis that have agreed to
do this with us
thank you dr. van care cough so we're
well over the hour and I'd like to
update the numbers for Hillenbrand swell
offline at least that's okay Helen I'll
be in contact with you I just hand of
you
see you on Monday thank you